possiamo iniziare chiacchiera legata
all'amore partiamo con un pochino di
cazzi vostri allora dichiarare l'amore
ciao ragazzi settimana scorsa vi avevo
detto che avrei detto al ragazzo di cui
sono innamorata che ormai era innamorata
ci siamo frequentati per tre mesi ma lui
deve fuori taglia quindi sapevo sarebbe
stata una cosa a termine eppure mi sono
innamorata naturalmente non andata a
buon fine ma passerà
amore aveva fatto bene almeno ti si è
tolta il peso e soprattutto sei stata
onesta intellettualmente con te stessa
che sennò uno può essere porta sempre
dietro ste cose avrei potuto fare di più
dire di più allora è colpa mia se non è
andata per carità del cielo per me è
fatto benissimo disse la busi l'anime
perché io invece poi di mio sono una
pusillanime ma solo un'ottima
consigliera la vera strategia è dire mi
piace e poi non parteciperebbe ragazzi
scrivete a tutti i vostri amici e
mandateli questo link perché ci sta per
svelare la vita lo sento mio diario
mondo tu ti senti mi piace molto è da
tanto tempo che non provavo una cosa
così ecco era incaricata però non
dipende dai conto di piace e basta
scompare intoppi non ti fai un po i
cazzi tuoi perché perché quella persona
dice ma come se ti piacciono tanto
perché lo stai sbagliando per me è così
da capire il film di paul bird non ha un
aspetto che ti soffoca è un affetto che
dona la libertà all'altra persona ma è
strano disse fai ovvio che quando i
sentimenti stanno in mezzo è tutto più
confusionario e più difficile ecco
perché in quel caso dovreste avere delle
persone in questo momento siamo lì e la
vigna che mi possono dare dei consigli
insieme a tutta quanta la città fra
tutte persone ci stanno guardando quando
ci sei tu devi vivere paradiso quando
non ci sei devi dare quel freddo gelido
della solitudine di precarietà pesenti
precarietà cosa mi dici quando e tipo il
coinquilino perché quello è un bel
casino specialmente quando ti rifiuta e
ti tocca viverci mente si porta le altre
a casa elisa qui devo essere onesto con
te devo parlarvi come se foste il mio
migliore amico elisa stefana sotto nas
smetti di palla sotto na basta sia ma
non è l'unica persona che c'è il cazzo
in questo mondo ok che ce l'ha in casa
ok che senti colatori di maschio ma che
parlava avuto il primo incontro con uno
che mi piaceva
novembre che non batteva chiodo è stato
un disastro provato a fargli capire cosa
volevo ma ha fatto orecchie da mercante
ero piena di aspettative perché da come
parlava sembra mi avrebbe rivoltato come
un calzino posso dirti una cosa è
successo e piaceva dopo questo
espediente non si piace più
ciao caro ne lavi ago non ho avuto la
chimica giusta corre in pista e non
avevo interesse di paris domande
interesse di cui parlavi su instagram
come che fai oggi da lì ha avuto la
conferma che non avevo un grande
interesse per lui e ciao siamo tra
interesse nel frattempo ho conosciuto
una persona online che fa parte di una
community ma questa cotta che mi stanno
uscendo vorrei soffocarla di questo
ragazzo mi piace il modo di fare vorrei
rimanere nell'ombra e meglio scrivere e
scrivo no perdonavi perché è meglio
soffocare questa coppa butta di più easy
to capito perché si inizi a fare troppo
il colpaccio ciao e ti fai nel frattempo
capite boccole i dati che rompe il cazzo
rimane molto più impresso un qualcosa un
pochino di più audace non è che devi
dire senti lo mandate a terni ginecologo
padre gheddo andare un pochino più
ammiccante e far capire subito in che
direzione sta andando permette subito di
capire se quella persona che per avere
un interesse e amen
se non ce l'ha meglio così se saresti
ritrovato l'ennesimo rugbista che magari
ha fatto sta lì ad annusare il cui
interesse momento in cui perché tele con
anima siete andati a letto per una
delusione azione ragazzi rugbisti quando
sono deludenti
viene voglia di metterci sotto il
tavolino a piangere due giorni se sei
davvero innamorato le strategie all'osso
nel tempo che trovano perché la
razionalità va a quel paese attento io
ormai il raggio lo come te in maniera
super basic assolutamente d'accordo che
ora sentiamo pure la controparte se
parliamo di strategie per me siamo in
una fase preliminare rispetto a una
relazione giusta non sa in una relazione
aspetto come poi essere innamorato di
una persona cara
allora io amo brevità
ma non i ragazzi se mi parlate di
strategie o domanda è a monte e allora
una domanda perché cosa intendi per fase
preliminare poi vedete ho rubato no no
quindi in realtà ancora non c'è niente è
quindi però ancora prima del fatto che
non ci sia niente mi fa venire il
carniere no devi dire usciamo trovato
vederci non è che stalin mezz'ora guarda
i boccoli a parlare di lei
la serie del cazzo no è l'idea che io
dopo di strategia non è tipo non ho
mollato gli usa per la tua strategia con
cui sta mica al telefono mi sono fermi
in atto in rete e telefonia me pronto
pezzato oggi che stavo praticamente a un
convegno di migliori amici e quindi a
questo convegno di male ma è subito
pensato per i vianello io sarò
strategica e va quindi cosa voglio ti
porto ad invitarmi io sono al
supermercato sto comprando il guanciale
perché porterà faccia l'amatriciana no
poverina clima scusa ma non è proprio
nessuno da evitare no dai
scusa ma vediamo noi gli mandai date in
fitti allora aspetta che ne comprende
più di guanciale ovviamente parentesi
ero già uscita da un ora dal
supermercato con sei chili e tre di
guanciale ok quindi ha fatto un attimo
che vedo by fif i brand un altro po di
guanciale allora dientro l'ottimo al
volo dentro al supermercato
allora sarà un secondo che voglio
tornare a invention dei migliori amici
che c'è questo film bellissimo che ci
possiamo guardare chi si chiama best
friends ai godi delle cantonali di
racconti giunta chiaro che tale o da
ciao hai visto come sei caduto nel mio
trouble breno quali ha ottenuto in
questo modo un appuntamento la animati
ma io ti devo vedere tu vieni a casa mia
nella tana del lupo rivedo poi scegliamo
c'è un uomo che conosco da tempo
vorrebbe mi trasferissi da lui fa
progetti assurdi professa amore
sconfinato per ogni due per tre scompare
in mano
riapparendo dopo qualche buon seme
iniziando tutta la tiritera ma che
problemi a cioè una versione identica in
realtà era una persona che faceva questi
piani nel momento in cui il suo sangue
dal cervello passava ad altre zone
beh non capendo in realtà che anche per
me questa persona era semplicemente
infiltra sangue dal cervello e auto ma
ne va intero league dicevo ok ok ma
quando si parla di interesse vero non
stiamo parlando di uno sprazzo e poi
scompare per un mese dovremmo iniziare a
trattarci come se no sono arrivati
sacchetti dell'immondizia anni di
relazione del mio ragazzo mi ha da poco
lasciata o meglio si è preso una pausa
che non sa quanto potrebbe durare
eravamo piccoli quando ci siamo messi
insieme siamo cresciuti insieme era
tutto perfetto
no non ci sono corna lui confuso io che
faccio sono distrutta e sto morendo
dalla voglia di cercarlo ci sono né
abili possibilità che lui ritorni da me
non so cosa gli sia successo a federico
e io non stavo chiedendo proprio la
persona sbagliata o non indovina e alla
mia esperienza quando io mi sono
comportato così e quando ho ricevuto
degli scorsi questo tipo di messaggio
un'altra il messaggio è che è molto
difficile
federica preferisco dirtelo l'immagine
tu se mia sorella ok purtroppo ci sta
andando avanti magari una persona si
renda conto le determinate cose non le
tornano e subentrano anche dei pensieri
nuovi quello che so io la mia esperienza
è che un tipo di rapporto così è più
probabile che finisca
l'unico motivo per cui ti chiede una
pausa e perché ovviamente ci sarà un
enorme affetto nei confronti un enorme
amore potremmo anche l'amore non basta e
quindi automaticamente più facile
a volte alcune persone me compreso dirti
ho bisogno un momento di pausa perché
quel momento di pausa ti permette un
attimo di allentare e di non sentirti
una bomba a orologeria che da momento
all'altro 17 finita non proprio nulla o
quella vi in tutta la mia vita non ho
mai avuto una relazione mi sono piaciuti
vari ragazzi però non sono mai stata
ricambiata
nessuno mi ha mai chiesto di uscire o
altro probabilmente per il mio aspetto
fisico che sto cercando di curare per il
mio carattere chiuso in quanto paura e
soffrire sono ferma su questo punto non
riesco ad uscirne le mie amiche mi hanno
consigliato di non essere timida di
aprirmi con gli altri vero sono
d'accordo con le tue amiche ma ricordati
una cosa non è mai un problema di
aspetto fisico dei carattere è solo una
questione di incastri il mondo funziona
sulla base in caratteri ciascuno di noi
è come tu troverai la tua anima gemella
metà della mela il tuo aquilone col
quale spiccare il volo non sta a chi sa
fare i problemi e soprattutto non
entrare in una modalità di ansie in
relazione a questa cosa l'unico
consiglio che mi sento dei dati che
magari la tua particolare evidenza
introversione fatto offrirete però
perché degli altri non me ne frega
niente sinceramente magari di cercare un
pochettino di superarla e ti parlo io
che sono e lo ribadisco ancora una volta
adesso di una spavalderia che nemmeno
belzebù me fa paura ma anzi via accolti
ma sono stata una bambina e una teenager
profondamente insicura io ero
terrorizzata da qualunque cosa io ho
capito che questa mia introversione
questa mia timidezza mi creava del
disagio ci ho lavorato ma se lo guarda
te lo devi fare per te prende del tuo
tempo per resettare il tuo rapporto con
te e magari pari passo mentre in sé fare
questa cosa e la di incominciare a
lavorare anche svolto da una relazione
di 10 anni è finita tempo fa vorrei
trovare qualcuno che già mi piace questa
idea di accoglienza ha detto danko 80
paura di rischiare e di poter rivivere
lo stesso fallimento abituando via la
solitudine per non rischiare di stare
male per qualcuno consigli quando da ios
adattata consigli che sono quattro anni
che sono solo come capolista
inizio tu perché così poi correggo il
tiro grazie credo di essere una
posizione abbastanza e con la da poterti
dare un consiglio per io sono quattro
anni che sono sola come un calzino
spaiato in lavatrice trascorso i primi
tre anni e mezzo avendo il completo
rifiuto verso qualunque tipologia di
rapporto appena arrivava il minimo
sentore di interesse vincolo anche
soltanto rimani a cena a casa mia a
metano con una tecnica che credevo molto
intelligente ma che chi mi ama
matt mascherato subito cioè attribuendo
all'altra persona tutta una serie di
difetti o meno esistenti più o meno
fondati po di oshii mattonelle del bagno
marroni non può i capi ma a quel punto
che marrone che mi ricordava quel trauma
quando le persone che mi amano mi hanno
fatto capire questa cosa quindi che io
vi stessi auto sabotando ho cercato un
po di addrizzare il tiro ora non sono
una professionista ma ti posso dire che
da completamente preclusiva adesso sono
passata ad accogliente quindi mi sento
nella disponibilità mentale fisica ed
anima di accogliere eventualmente
qualcuno te dovette passare davanti a me
io pure mi ritrovo a volte essere un
pochino all'interno di quel mondo lì ci
sono momenti nei quali sono più
predisposto momenti nei quali sono
almeno predisposto ma vi insegno subito
una cosa ragazzi il fatto che voi siate
più predisposti o meno predisposti non
cambierà un cazzo quando si è pronti che
sia a ri [ __ ] a rincontrare a
fidanzarsi quello che pare non è detto
che la vita la fortuna e le circostanze
di vengano incontro che fai ti butti
sulle varie app incontri della gente
stai lì alla ricerca dell'anaconda
perduta e a volte ti lanci in queste
situazioni e fai più cazzate che altro
pigliatevela con calma guardatevi
attorno se c'è una persona che vi
interessa sappiate che siete già di per
sé fortunati ringraziate il cielo che
ancora interessarvi di qualcuno vuol
dire che siete vivi che respirate che
avete un battito è una cosa positiva
se una persona vi piace un anno e tre
mesi guetta con la mia ragazza li
vediamo ogni giorno io appena apro bocca
lei si aggira reagisce male io sono uno
che mette il dialogo al primo posto che
con una semplice chiacchiera voglia
sentire le nostre anime sfiorarci con
lei purtroppo non è così io non sto bene
in questa relazione infatti sto
decidendo di chiuder la vita facendo
molte domande su me stesso perché lei mi
dice continuamente che la faccio sentire
in colpa e cose simili
voglio chiudere voi che dite sarò
veramente sincera nei confronti c'è
un'incompatibilità di fondo io gli dico
subito che non tutto può essere un anima
che se sfiora è molto importante secondo
me innanzitutto capire anche quando non
puoi cercare una roba nel momento in cui
non c'è una predisposizione ad altra
parte magari un momento difficile e tu
più cerchi che cerca la mia anima è più
nemmeno a di lanciarti addosso un
pianoforte a coda detto ciò è una che
strumentalizza lei una è probabilmente
non è soddisfatta all'interno di questa
relazione magari non lo sei anche te
però da come si comporta leila quel tipo
di atteggiamento della persona non
soddisfatta e solitamente le cose che
non tornano sono il sesso la personalità
della persona che davanti o le scelte di
vita quindi è esattamente come miri a
martina 94 ti dice si vuole far mollare
e il fatto che lei si sente in colpa sai
perché è dovuto è dovuto al fatto che di
base una manipolatrice di base c'è un
sacco dei problemi cioè mi fai sentire
in colpa e veramente una roba da non
risolto con il proprio passato si dice o
semplicemente ti tradisce è vero perché
a volte queste persone i loro errori
cercando di buttarsi su di te quasi come
se fosse una colpa tua che loro sentono
la merda perché se comportano di merda
non è follia
la cosa però positiva è che lui è già
riuscito a giudicare dalle sue parole è
fatto che lei gli siano esse già rotto
il calcio è nel centrati
mandarlo interrotto le parole ti dico io
cosa le devi dire non ho interesse a
stare con una persona che si comporta
così una persona con la quale litigo
ogni giorno mi manda in atti comunque
non siano compatibili
[Musica]